[Music]
it's really good work good work between
these two teams who
you know they they took care of us
pretty good last year
and um we knew it's gonna be competitive
so it's been a good couple days if
that's a fight to you man you've never
been in a fight
so we just don't want any punches thrown
mike frable tom brady there's a little
bit of a skirmish yesterday a scuffle it
was called a brawl by jim wyatt of the
titans official website apparently it
wasn't much of a brawl but it inspired
today's draft our draft for today is
which nfl head coach would you want on
your side in a fight the coin toss has
been tossed we now determine the first
pick with a trivia question and today is
the day that i have to answer the
question big cat go ahead okay michael
mike frable and one other player were
traded to the chiefs in 2009 for a
second round draft pick
who was that other player
oh it was matt castle
come on ask me a hard question
go ahead now you decide i get the first
pick i defer yes
okay all right mike rebel
yeah that's the best come on
that's that's your creativity that no
it's not the best pick you're going mike
grebel i guess
all right is an absolute beast i when i
was at the combine two years ago i saw
mike rabel and he's been on our show
and he's a fan and i you know i i text
him every now and then not to brag
that's not a bragging statement of fact
he slapped me in the back
and i almost puked a lung out he has
big hands
strength and you saw this with with him
getting in that skirmish he still wants
it he still wants a little bit of that
action you know he's about that action
boss so i'm taking mike frable that's
the easiest pick number one he would be
so mad at me if i didn't pick him so i'm
getting back in his good graces by
picking him number one
yeah look i i
i considered him uh because he was an
nfl linebacker and uh there's another
former nfl linebacker though that i put
a little and i know he's older but he
was part of that 85 bears defense and he
seems like a nice guy
when he knows that everyone's watching
but if you saw all or nothing this year
halftime at the steelers panthers game
last year i i i think i may have peed a
little when i was listening to ron
rivera chewing into his team and f-bomb
this and f on that and if i'm going to
battle i want ron rivera the panthers
head coach next to me
did you get you need to get your
prostate checked if that's happening
that may have been the issue um all
right i'll go
easy pick for my number two doug marone
just an absolute beast of a human being
if you've ever s you know been next to
doug marone and you get a you get a look
at those legs he was an offensive
lineman he coached offensive line he
played football he's been in football
he's a football guy doug marone he's
he's a new york guy you know you don't
want to get he loves baloney i go on and
on and on doug marone is someone i would
want in the trenches with me
is this just a draft of all your head
coach friends
yes pretty much pretty much no but
seriously doug
have you been next to him he's a he is a
mess of a man
i've sent you a picture of doug marone
in shorts because the the the width of
his leg from the knee to the foot it
never narrows it never tapers it is
literally the trunk of a tree
stats we got to get before the show ends
we have to have the picture of myself
pft and doug marone at the jacksonville
jaguars pool where we all had our shirts
off so
he's huge he's a huge guy and really one
tough guy
do we really want to subject the
audience to that yeah i've seen that
it's breakfast in some time zones it's
good uh
all right you left somebody on the board
who i think would show up and kick ass
and take names and he is the chargers
head coach anthony lynn
former nfl running back he looks like he
could throw on a helmet and go out on
the field right now and he's i don't
know how he played running back in the
nfl because you know most the ideal
running back size is that five seven
five eight you know about my height uh
anthony lynn is a big guy and he is
thick and i have a feeling that if it
was going to go down he is taking
absolutely no prisoners give me anthony
lynn how many c's thick
uh four
four no no not him no no he's no he's no
he's he's uh and he's looking a little
thick in that photo there but every time
i've ever seen him he looks like he's
he's in that you know that that
mid-season marathon shape where he's you
know he's got some endurance if the
fight goes more than a round or two he's
going to outlast you on points i don't
want to pump up your picks but it's a
good pick obviously uh everyone knows
the story of him surviving that car
crash he's a tough as nails guy and uh
definitely would want him on my side in
a fight all right my last pick it's an
easy one
bill belichick because bill belichick
comes with ernie adams so now i have
doug marone mike vrabel doing the the
tough grind it out fighting and then i
have bill belichick and ernie adams
sitting there doing some strategic work
that's the easiest pick i
absolutely
dominated you you could pick mike dicker
and a hurricane in this last pick and i
still beat you
yeah but here's the thing bill belichick
all due respect and and he's the
greatest coach of all time in any sport
he's old
at a certain point the spirit is willing
but the flesh is weak what's he going to
do to you he's like pushing 70 man
the brain and ernie adams ernie adams
comes with bill belichick that's a pal i
want that on the list
bill belichick parentheses with ernie
adams
so so ernie is the mickey he's going to
be in the corner telling uh telling bill
belichick rocky what to do sure
this has been
even even for you i'm shocked by your
your ineptitude with this draft even for
you
you know i'm not i'm not done yet
oh yeah i know i said i said you could
pick anyone here and you won't win no
well okay but what what is th
the key element in any fight if you
really want to have a knock down drag
out and you want to win and you want
someone to go in there and you know that
they're going to get it done
what's the real element that you need to
win a fight between human beings mike
brabel
no you need crazy right and i'm not
saying actual crazy you need the
appearance of crazy like the best fight
you win is the one that you can avoid
all together and i know a guy one time
who had was taking on like 10 dudes but
he just acted crazy and nobody wanted to
mess with him so give me adam gase the
jets head coach because i'm not saying
he is crazy but if he wants to look
crazy if he wants to out crazy you and
get you to never take that first punch
you look at him after you took the
smelling salts hit last week you're not
messing with adam gase
you are saying okay fine we're not going
to have a fight today
oh i'm sorry sir i didn't mean to bump
into you here's everything in my wallet
and the keys to my car please leave me
alone that's what you need to go into
battle you need the guy that's going to
scare the other side into not fighting
you adam gaye's final answer i win
all right uh you didn't win that was a
terrible effort by you a couple that
just missed it for me uh actually your
coach mike zimmer
basically he said he would lose an eye
for football that guy if you want to
talk about crazy if you go with mike
zimmer i would have had a little more
respect for your draft as it currently
stands i don't respect it whatsoever
andy reid just the size maybe i'm
thinking like an old school yokozuma
situation where he comes off the top
rope so i'd throw him on there and then
john gruden john gruden if you could you
basically i would just hold up one of
those play cards of just derek carr's
face and he the it would be like a bull
seeing red and he would just go crazy on
you
like bobby boucher right yeah you have
the trigger and off he goes i i thought
about frank reich or doug peterson just
because those guys who played
quarterback in the nfl they're huge
they're giant i mean they're well
proportioned but like i remember being
shocked when i met boomer siason you see
these guys on tv and they look normal
size and then you sit and it's like
where's the beanstalk man i mean and
rike and peterson just that big giant
come after you and and can take whatever
you can give out and just will
ultimately just like slowly crush you
into the ground so i thought about reich
and i thought about peterson i bottom
line is i don't want to mess with any of
these guys none of them no uh
so uh i'll take i guess i would take any
if if i'm the other alternative in the
fight any of them would be a better
option than me
yeah i'd mess with pete carroll i think
i could take pete carroll
i would no no pete you put a football in
pete carroll's hands and he like loses
30 years of age like that have you ever
seen that he transforms into a guy half
his age the moment you put a football in
his hands i wouldn't matte either i'd
mess with cliff kingsbury he's too much
of a pretty boy i i'd take him down
doesn't want don't want to get hit in
the face
yeah exactly knock his sunglasses off
we're about to hit you in the face with
this look away if you have a squeamish
stomach
listen
it doesn't do justice to the doug marone
legs you are not gonna knock doug marone
down you you may be able to hit him
punch him kick him stab him you are not
going to knock him over he's got a base
that he's never going to give in all
right let's recap wait let me just
comment real quick on this picture mike
uh you do not have to adjust your tv yes
my nipples are that large
did
what did you have to do to convince him
to do that
nothing he was down for doug maron is a
football guy i love him
all right mike frable doug maron and
bill belichick with ernie adams as his
cut man
i've got ron over anthony lynn and adam
gase because you need somebody who can
convince the other guy in the fight that
you are just crazy enough to do anything
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports